Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata. Adesso
tantissime volte ci chiedete qual è il
segreto delle nostre ricette. Perché
quello che facciamo noi
all'interno di questa cucina di mio
cugino, il Gugino si...anche mia da oggi (Roberta)...anche di Roberta da oggi
Solo che suona meglio il Gugino
piuttosto che la Guberta...Come mai quello
che facciamo qua dentro ha una marcia in più
ha quel sapore che nessun altro ha? E'
semplice, perché all'interno di ogni
piatto dall'inizio di questa rubrica,
quattro mesi fa, fino ad oggi ci sono
sempre i germi di mio fratello
Hai fatto?...E noi vogliamo dire basta al colpo di
tosse che ogni volta sentiamo
all'interno di questa cucina e che ci ha
rotto i c******i. Ecco perché con l'avvento del cambio di
stagione abbiamo pensato di fare un
qualcosa di nuovo
ossia rubare come sempre la ricetta
che ha fatto qualcun altro perché noi
crearne manco morti....per produrre un
rimedio naturale contro l'influenza
la tosse. Ora io per i rimedi naturali non è che sia
proprio...di base non mi curo e aspetto
che la morte arrivi, però perché non
tentare questa ricetta e soprattutto
quanto è bello avere una curcuma con
ancora dei confetti attaccati come bomboniera del matrimonio? Di chi è? Di tua madre (Chef Mario)
Di mia madre? Del matrimonio di mia madre? No, è presa da tua madre (Chef Mario)
Chissà quale dei suoi amici ha avuto questo
cattivo gusto
Che dire, partiamo quindi con gli
ingredienti. Ah tra parentesi ringraziamo
Gabry Ponte come è che si chiama? Gabry Auritiano.
Gabry Ponte non è tipo "delle streghe"
Lui ci dice "Innanzitutto degli
ingredienti saranno: curcuma, la radice di
zenzero fresca". Gianmarco da quanto è
che c'era quella radice di zenzero?
Questa qua la utilizzate per il presepe
l'anno prossimo
Pure a lei non le sembrava...cioè, è buono secondo lei. Non si presenta dal bell'aspetto (Chef Mario)
Peperoncino macinato, uno zitrone, miele.
Guarda che il pepe nero non c'è. Sicuro? (Chef Mario)
Poi il pepe nero fa male. Non è vero in piccole dosi fa
bene (Chef Rico)
No il pepe nero non fa bene, per quanto
io lo adori
Quella è la lista degli ingredienti (Chef Mario)...Gabry per favore non facciamo
scherzetti. Partiamo subito con la
preparazione
Prendiamo una ciotola...vabbè un bicchiere.
Prendiamo innanzitutto un bicchiere
Per prima cosa aggiungiamo un cucchiaio di
curcuma. Quali sono le proprietà della
curcuma? Anticancerogena? E' la spezia migliore...antitumorale?
Ma non solo quello eh. Cioè è proprio una
spezia con un botto di proprietà (Chef Rico).
Il parere del medico. "E' una pianta
antiossidante...antiossidante... antinfiammatoria...antinfiammatoria
Svolge un'azione depurativa, benefica e colagoga". Cosa cosa cosa?
Colagoga. Depurativa? E colagoga (Chef Mario). Che vuol dire?(Chef Rico)...Colagoga?
Scusate qualche medico.... colagoga è
una parola in italiano? Ho un po' di problemi
colagoga. Qui lui aggiunge un cucchiaio di
zenzero macinato, nel frattempo ti chiedo
Gianmarco a questo punto le proprietà
dello zenzero. E' pazzesco lo zenzero! (Chef Rico)
Mamma mia tu proprio il medico eh? "Beh la curcuma
ottime proprietà, lo zenzero pazzesco!"
Se io sono un medico tu sei uno Chef (Chef Rico)
"Lo zenzero ha tante proprietà, è pazzesco innanzitutto. A scopo curativo contro nausee
infezioni e infiammazioni...cioè...uno dei rimedi naturali più efficaci...vedi?
Aiuta ad alleviare il mal di testa, dolori mestruali...ah io ho problemi di quello
La digestione favorisce? Certo (Chef Mario)
Anche se il mio foniatra mi ha detto che con
lo zenzero non...Chi? (Chef Ottavio)...il mio foniatra
E' tipo colagoga...Troppo zenzero però rischia di
irritare e di creare anzi reflusso
gastrite. "Aiuta il sistema immunitario, curando raffreddore e mal di gola"(Chef Mario)
Tiè! E' perfetto per questa
stagione direi no? "Previene il diabete"(Mario). Lo zenzero? (Rico). "Riduce la glicemia" (Mario)
Mamma mia mettine due di cucchiai (Rico). Ma ha altre proprietà? E' anche antitumorale. "Aiuta a prevenire
la comparsa di alcuni tumori, favorisce la
distensione muscolare"
E' tipo Dio lo zenzero (Chef Mario).  Cioè se tu hai il
raffreddore, tu prendi questo qui "Bahhh"
e dipingi una parete di muco. All'interno di questa rubrica è bello c*********e, è bello divertirsi
però perché non provare anche a fare qualcosa
di utile, tipo chiuderla...oook
Il grembiule Guglielmo! (Chef Rico). Cacchio il grembiule! Come facciamo?
Ok...In realtà se lo sta mettendo qua (Chef Rico)
Un cucchiaio e mezzo di
miele. Vuoi sapere le proprietà del miele? (Chef Mario)
Te ne prego! Ragazzi il miele (Rico)... Aspetta prima
di sentire...fa benissimo! (Chef Rico)
"Antibatterico, antibiotico addirittura, utilizzato per il trattamento della diarrea...oh buono per te Erri
"Efficace contro la stipsi" (Mario)...Ragazzi miei! (Rico). Sapete cos'è la stipsi? L'opposto della diarrea è la stipsi
Ah quindi tipo i sassi (Chef Mario). Questo c***i. Ah Gu mo che ci penso l'olio di semi non ho portato (Mario)
Una curiosità sul miele. "Zeus ottene il primo nutrimento dal miele di Panacride, ape che viveva sull'Ida" (Mario)
Beh ringraziamo Panacride e...diciamo che
noi non siamo solamente ottima cucina ma
siamo anche cultura, possiamo dirlo? Mitologia
in questo momento. Un pizzico di
peperoncino...Com'è il peperoncino Enrico? E' un po', irrita però, quindi bisogna ...(Rico)
mettere un pizzico giusto? Ma non serve per
la pressione? Non è un regolatore della
pressione insieme all'aglio? L'aglio se ne
magni tanto te mette ko (Rico). Mette ko gli
altri. Stimola la circolazione sanguigna, contrasta l'insorgere di batteri, alza il
colesterolo e attiva il metabolismo".
Madre santa ragazzi. Antibatterico, antistaminico
Davvero il pepe nero? Il Peperoncino (Mario). Ah
"Il pepe nero è un alleato della salute...un alleato della
salute?...stimolare il metabolismo e
favorisce la digestione"
E poi il succo di uno zitrone. Io intanto glie lo...no no
Il seme hai messo il seme (Rico)...eh l'ho visto!
"Il limone è battericida, antisettico e
antitossico, un bicchiere di salute" (Mario)...Quindi
possiamo dire che all'interno di questo
coso ci stanno tutte cose che fanno benissimo! Te credo che ti cura...(Mario). Ti cura qualsiasi cosa
questo coso. "Facilita la perdita di peso" (Mario). Madre santa!
"Pulisce la pelle...uno shortino si sarà fatto (Rico)
Guarda che te devi prende tre cucchiaini al giorno eh. E' un concentrato di Zeus (Mario)
Zeus stesso, non è che tu fai questa roba qui
e te la devi finire tutta quanta, lo
sciroppo della tosse te lo scoli
Mattina, pranzo e cena, per rovinarti
tutti e tre i pasti secondo me. Tra
parentesi all'interno del video dice "Cura
l'influenza in un giorno...ma che cacchio dice! (Rico)
Enrico mo te lo porti a casa questo.
Oddio ragazzi vomito!
No non è infuso. "Così". Per me è abbastanza saporito (Mario). Ci vuole un altro po' di miele perché il suo è più
denso. Almeno il miele un po' addolcisce (Mario)...si, sta m***a!
Dal più schifiltoso all'ultimo
quindi Enrico, a te il primo
cucchiaio che se poi un altro ci poggia
le labbra tu...guarda io sono malato. Enrico da anni
da anni. Ma siete tutti malati ma che è un
lazzaretto? Vieni Enri. Beh si ben...triso
E' buono. Ma di che sa? Di zenzero, curcuma, molto miele. Ma senti tutto? Non sento peperoncino, pepe
Però così vi state contagiando a vicenda (Mario)
No perché adesso l'ho rimesso qua dentro "Zzzz".
Non sento il limone. Io sto pure bene
vorrei dire. Lasciamone anche un po' a Pierfra che sta male anche lui (Mario). A Pierfra gli
lasciamo solo la m***a! Quando noi facciamo
qualcosa di buono mio cugino non vede
niente, quando c'è qualcosa di orribile
il suo frigo è pieno di "Beh, qualora
volessi un  pochino di sciroppo per la tosse"
Ti ha stupito eh? (Rico). Fa c****e!
E tu non senti limone? Tu non hai la
lingua! Chef Ottavio nelle nostre cucine,
ti è andata di m***a oggi. No un cucchiaio Giulia
Non è malvagio. Ma tu non lo senti il limone? Si lo sento
Devo dire già mi sento meglio!...Questo qui è ottimo perché ti
fa vomitare...l'influenza. Vai roby. Un applauso a Chef Rocco
Bleee, no! Allora ragazzi
purtroppo la videocamera si è spenta
proprio quando ha assaggiato Gianmarco
quindi sarai l'unico che sta bene e che
prenderà due volte...devo fa anche le
stesse battute di prima vero? No no tu puoi essere
onesto. Dillo!
Qual è il tuo parere onesto. Che è
discreto. Vale la pena, se state male vale
la pena. Poi cioè sa di limone tanto, molto
di limone. Gianmarco non è capace di
rifare una cosa per la seconda volta
Non senti il limone? Cioè sa di limone tanto. Eh-sa-molto-di-limone-e-alla-fine-se-state-male
Molte persone non sentono  i sapori quando sono
influenzate. Questa è nuova. E me ne vado
così ragazzi! Siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
puntata, io vi faccio solamente una
richiesta. Se vi va e state male, potete fare da
cavie per favore e mi fate sapere se
effettivamente questo miscuglio ha
funzionato in qualche modo? Perché io ho
dei dubbi per quanto possono essere
benefiche e pazzesche le proprietà della
roba che ci abbiamo messo dentro. Taggatemi
su Instagram oppure semplicemente scrivetemi
un commento qua sotto. Chiedo scusa a
tutti quanti i medici. Tre volte al giorno
guarda che stai un fiore, stai un fiore proprio (Rico). Stai un fiore perché non c'arrivi...tu sei pazzesc...Noi ci
vediamo la prossima Domenica, sempre con un'altra puntata di Cucina Buttata e fino ad allora
*lingua straniera*
Hai presente quando su Sky cambi la lingua?
Di colpo diventa un'altra cosa
ho fatto questo. Che dire ci vediamo la
prossima settimana e vi auguro a tutti...
Comunque non fa bene questo...(Rico)
Non è servito a niente. Enrico tu secondo me hai un qualcosa di psicologico. Questo coso te lo devi
iniettare nel cervello. E così la chiudiamo. Ciao ragazzi. Alla prossima puntata. Ciao